the first thing you'd probably notice
would be the giant insect likee
creatures one of the most iconic was the
Mega nura this insect resembled a
modern-day
dragonfly except with a major twist it
had a wingspan of up to 75
cm yeah scarier than that though it was
carnivorous hunting down other insects
and small
amphibians hopefully it doesn't come for
you so that thing is in the sky but on
land you'll have the arthr plura this
millipede like creature could grow up to
2 and 1/2 M long luckily it wouldn't go
after you it preferred munching on
decomposing vegetation another creepy
looking insect was the
pulmonoscorpius this was a giant
scorpion that mostly roamed the sampier
areas of Earth they could grow 70 cm
long